how's it going everyone it's Warren and
we have a brand new Avengers in-game
plot synopsis to talk about now we've
talked about a few of these in the past
but this one mentioned some very
interesting things including the mention
of how the MC will not be the same after
Avengers in game so I'll go ahead and
read the synopsis word by word and then
break it down after and quick reminder
about my giveaway if you'd like to
interfere your chance to win five imax
tickets all you have to do subscribe to
my channel like this video and comment
down below with your thoughts and your
favorite superhero or villain
so again word for word here is the new
synopsis Fano snapped his fingers in
Avengers infinity war and half the life
in the universe
instantly dissolved now a ragged group
of surviving warriors including Captain
America Black Widow Iron Man Thor and
the Hulk works to counteract the Mad
Titans genocidal action since our heroes
couldn't stop Thanos the first time what
makes them think they can win in a
rematch the answer may be in
overwhelming power thanks to Captain
Marvel or in the tiniest spaces between
atoms accessible to ant-man Avengers in
game will rewrite the Marvel Cinematic
Universe as we know it when it's all
over nothing will be the same okay so
there are a few big things to talk about
here the first paragraph is something
that has been in almost every synopsis
that we've heard before but the second
paragraph is relatively new it says the
key to defeating Thanos could be Captain
Marvel's overwhelming power and ant-man
Captain Marvel is now out in theaters so
we know she's just amazingly strong more
power in a fight is obviously always
good however when they refer to ant-man
they are referring to the tiniest spaces
between atoms which of course is
referencing the quantum realm now we've
known that the quantum realm was going
to play a really big part in Avengers
and game for a pretty long time now
especially as of recently where we've
heard about time vortexes and ant-man
and the wasp and we've seen all these
leaked photos of the Avengers wearing
these white suits believed to be for
traveling inside of the quantum realm
and it's mostly believed that the
Avengers will use the quantum realm to
travel back in time and I think that
this connects directly with the last two
sentences where it says Avengers in game
will rewrite the Marvel Cinematic
Universe as we know it when it's all
over nothing will be the same and that
is because if the event
go back in time and start changing the
past the future will be affected if you
change the past you change the future
and right now everything that we know is
pointing towards time-travel right now
this synopsis points towards time travel
but time travel is so dangerous that if
you go to the past and change one little
thing the whole entire future could be
rewritten for example if you go back in
time to the Battle of New York from the
first Avengers movie and you take Loki's
scepter and you get the mine stone from
it then all of a sudden the future has
no more vision no more Scarlet Witch
no more Quicksilver the events of age of
Ultron never happened so you have to be
extremely careful when you travel back
through time but unfortunately time
travel is pretty much the avengers only
option right now and this is where I
think those last lines are going to come
into play saying that the future of the
MCU will be rewritten I definitely think
that this is going to happen and I
definitely think that this is what
Marvel wants so they can move on to the
next phase we know that in-game is going
to end the first ten years story arc so
how do you start a new phase and a new
story arc in the MCU well you rewrite it
and it's a good thing because you can
rewrite it in a way that gives our
current heroes that we know and love a
happy ending but you can also introduce
new characters and have new leaders and
introduce people like the Fantastic Four
and the x-men so people may be afraid
that in-game is going to rewrite the
Marvel Cinematic Universe but I think it
can be a really good thing but
nonetheless it is a really big deal and
I'm curious to see how it plays out in
avengers endgame but let me know what
you think about this plot synopsis and
let me know what you think about
Avengers endgame rewriting the Marvel
Cinematic Universe as we know it
let me know your thoughts in the
comments down below and again don't
forget to subscribe comment and like the
video so you can enter the giveaway and
stay up to date on everything relating
to Avengers in game as always thank you
all so much for watching
woof woof
[Music]